Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
so I haven't done one of these videos in
a quite a while but I gotta share this
with y'all this video is probably over a
year old but for those of you who have
not seen this video this video was about
a guy who gets into it with the bouncer
after he got kicked out of club and he
tries to get back in there are so many
things wrong with this video I don't
even know where to begin
let's start with this your friend is
getting his ass whooped and the best
thing you could be a professional
witness you man you are the sorriest
homie on earth you know what you are you
are one of those mothers aren't you I
got your back son but way back here
though I just now you think it's bad
enough as it is right but check it out
he goes from threatening with the
lawsuit she keeping him financial advice
let's go to the other guy count how many
times he got his ass pushed in the flow
baby ball is a very funny drug if you
have enough of it it doesn't actually
increase your fighting ability
personally for watching this video
apparently you believe in the saying the
bigger they are the harder they fall
don't you here's some real advice [ __ ]
the bigger they are the faster you run
what a big brother says exactly you
don't say it again how are you gonna
tell the big a dude from the rebound oh
and look at this part right here in the
middle of a fight you go check to see if
you dropped your money are you sure what
it's nothing else just pick it up my
nuts that bro fell on the floor fell on
the floor like I said before
alcohol is a hell of a drug I've heard
some people say some of the craziest
[ __ ] there you go
no you know [ __ ] oh wow I'm sure she's
got a penis so here's the mall story
don't get drunk don't fight don't don't
drop fight don't have people record your
you know yeah it is easy idiot idiot
receipt is that it is that what
yeah I keep Betty right beside me cuz
I'm gonna ride me keep mo bills in the
Cosmi look I get things might get low
ride me like that on my ear sippin ok
cos Halloween because it's hard still
I'm young and I'm lagging
No
into us
you
Oh
so what do I do people sending foolish
products at me in my situation
the general selfish hopper being selfish
and greedy mm would you push the limits
hoping that you might be but I have ever
attempted a breakup sex
Oh
you trust me
Oh